I'm responding to marc kremers a video I
was taken by the interest in an
individual action in a participant my
name is Africa Berkeley I'm a
participant in this year's Davos
conference and I find it very
interesting to see that individuals can
actually accomplish quite a bit I'm
powered by a strong idea that resonates
with other people individuals can
amplify the power of that idea as they
travel around and meet other people
other people don't have to be our
powerful people I don't have to be
well-known people they just make people
who have an interest in the success of
that idea so I was at enthusiastic about
your video and i responded hoping this
will add to the conversation thank you